Well THAT went horribly- or well, i m stupid
We have no idea, we have no idea who won.
But we do know how to win whedy tell won in the-in the next one.
(Marki-brainfart)
*all laughing*
[Tyler] I like that one..
*Markimoo regrets word choices* *J-Fred rubs Markimoo's lovely arm*
[Tyler] I like that one ALOT.
anyway..
[Tyler] you gonna keep that?
yeah i'm gonna keep that! I don't do second takes-
So, what we're gonna do now is
we're each gonna come up with our own action,
do it backwards,
and see who can guess, what we were doing.
And whoever guesses it!
Gets like, a point or somethin..
[J-Fred] Sure!
yeah a point!
[Bryan] Gold star!
[Matt] I dun want any...
yeah that too!
[Matt] I don't want any points ;_;
You'll get a hundred thousand subscribers!!
:O
Even the pe- the cameramen can guess!
Connor can guess! EVERYONE can guess!
[J-Fred] i'm crying..
wait-
*ding ding ding*
*girly sobbing noises*
*realization of a terrible mistake*
*accepts his fate*
*wishing he had hair to rub*
[Tyler] Getting Married!
[Tyler] A wedding while sitting down...
[J-Fred] Iii can't even guess (??)
*laughter*
[Mark] Okay, I got it.
Y-Your buddies put you in a chair, put a blindfold on ya-
[J-Fred] nope!
[Mark] okay nevermind then :c
[Matt] okay my turn, my turn!
[J-Fred] I'm a person.
*brothers have become one*
[Matt] oh, you're...you're like a celebrity?
[J-Fred] mmm...I guess you could say that.
[Matt] ...mmmmMark.
[J-Fred] mm.. not quite so popular
*laughter*
[Matt] J-Fred.
[J-Fred] A little more popular..
[Mark] How many guesses does he get??
*laughter*
[J-Fred] It was Matthias dying his hair!!! Cause it looks so BAD!
*Angry man-children arguing because they lost*
[Tyler] YEAAAAH I WIIIIN
Take THAT and rewind it back~
*mistakes being made*
*mistakes have been made.*
*sobbing*
[Matthias] Ready?
*ding ding ding*
*polite regurgitation*
*lackluster motivational fist bumps*
*poorly executed ballroom dancing*
*running man*
*TWUUNK*
*laughter*
*confused mumbles*
[Tyler] Hunter, that killed his prey, and then cooked it.
[Matt] YEEEHS
*various wows*
♬Now play it in reveeeerse~ ♬
*accurate simulation of Matt trying to get a date*
[Tyler] This is gonna be really tough to do..
*ding ding ding*
*....eeuuUUUUUUUUUGHHHHAAGHGAAAAUAAAHHH*
yyaiidununaethsis
[J-Fred] okay lets, lets break this down. He...
*various guesses*
[J-Fred] then he was like, sliding...
He was MARK, HITTING the wall with the Go-Kart!!!
*surprised yells*
Play it back~!
*Markiplier's decent into hell*
[Mark] Wooowhohow.
[Matt] Low blow, dude.
[Mark] Yeah you have to check out the video on THEIR channel *laughter*
-to know what we're talking about!
For context, here's a clip.
[Mark] AAAAAAAAAH!
*Markimoo smash*
But you can click that clip to get over to their channel!
[Tyler] I guess yours exactly right so we both get points-
[Matt] And I guessed your's exactly right.
[Tyler] no he di- [Matt] no that was me.
[Mark] I'll tally the points afterwards.
[Tyler] okay but, but that was legit. Well done.
[Mark] That was, that was pretty good.
[J-Fred] Because I broke it down.
[Bryan] Ready?
*ding ding ding*
*failed twerking*
*HSM revival*
*this mating dance isn't going so well dude...*
*hangs head in shame*
[Matt] ...snowboarding..
[J-Fred] that was easy..
[Mark] yeah that wasnt (??)
[Tyler] Shaun White Snowboarding.
[Bryan] yis
[Mark] nAAWH CMON, bullshit, it's not ~Shaun White~
[Mark] nah fuck you!
[Bryan] alright see that in reverse!
*and now you see a dancing idiot in its natural habitat*
*....so majestic....*
[Bryan] nahahah I wasn't, I wasn't thinking Shaun White.
[Mark] yeah of course!!
*chatting*
[Matt] (??)..how many subscribers?
[Mark] You made me forget what I was gonna do, I was so angry.
Ready?
*ding ding ding*
*the -true- agony of erectile disfunction*
(it's okay Mark, no judging here.)
*Pirouette away from your feelings*
*failed serenade*
*fighting your feelings*
[J-Fred + Tyler] Pole Vaulter getting hit in the nuts!!!
[Tyler] dAMMIT....he was, it was from the Olympic thing
Rewind that!
*trying to catch a real live girl*
*rejection via nutshot*
*yet again, the mark has failed at capturing a female*
*you'll get em someday, bud.*
[Tyler] It happened in the Olympics-
*chattering*
[Tyler] Like, he landed on his pole and got hit in the nuts.
*groans of discomfort*
[J-Fred] Wait, what pole are we talking about~?
[Matt] ammright?
*crickets and muffled laughter*
[J-Fred] You have beautiful blue eyes, i've never realized that.. (J-Tyler fanfics begin)
[Mark] Waooow
[Tyler] I do I just never wanted t-
*awk laughs*
[Mark] Okay, Alright, we're all done here.
This was a buncha bullshit and I'm pretty sure
everyone's gonna forget that we ever did this one.
So, but thank you everybody for being here!
...It was fun while it lasted.
*slap*
*anguished yell*
.....So hope you enjoyed it too. If you wanna see another video-
*boing*
-that we did over on uh, Team Edges channel
You can check out the link in the description below
or the fancy new annotation thing over there~
You got the new annotation system?
Available on desktop AND mobile, you can click through anywhere~
[Matt] It's beautiful...
[Mark] It's very beautiful. So anyway, click on that when it shows up
*slide whistle sound*
...20 seconds from the end of the video
because there's a physical limitation for it-
Anyway! Thanks again everybody so much for watching-
And as always, see 'ya in the next one.
~BUH-BYE~
[Jazzy music fade out]